So my kids started their new co op this week.
Um, if you don't know,
we are a homeschool family.
This past year was our first year of homeschool,
and I did everything
except for the things that I did outsource to lessons or programs.
I taught them ELA, Science,
social studies, um,
and all of their art and music stuff,
for the most part at home.
And this time we're doing a co op this year.
And it has been a really interesting journey,
because when I first started to homeschool,
I always said, oh,
I would do a pot where I would do a co op.
there has to be one or two days a week that they're with other kids
and they're out of the house, and,
you know, I can get stuff done.
And that just didn't manifest.
In the Charleston area.
There were a lot of homeschool groups and co ops and stuff,
but just none that really fit what we were looking for,
because they were either Christian based
with the curriculum they were using,
which is fine. We just.
That is not the faith that we follow,
so it wasn't gonna be a good fit for us.
And or they are super outdoorsy unschoolers,
crunchy. Um,
and that wasn't our philosophy on educating either.
So it was really, really tricky.
And I think I finally have found, like,
an educational home and community,
and I'm so, so excited.
It has been touted As a academically rigorous, um,
but secular based education.
And definitely incorporates a lot of nature as well.
And outdoor time and social,
emotional learning and tolerance.
And all of the stuff that we were already looking for.
They just. They just had the whole package. Um,
and I'm really, really excited for my kids.
They already seem to be, like,
making social connections in their grade levels.
Um, the kids are separated by age range,
and then they can definitely do classes that are for, um,
kids a little bit older or younger,
depending on their aptitude at that subject.
So it's a very fluid concept.
It looks like when, you know,
if a kid is not challenged in the class,
they can move to a different class.
That's maybe with older kids.
That will keep them challenged and engaged,
which I really like that option.
That's one of the things I love about homeschool
is that you're continuously adjusting to meet your kids needs.
Now, that doesn't mean I don't expect to be able to change classes,
like in the middle of a unit or in the middle of the lesson,
but again, I don't know.
This is all brand new.
We will be doing a take home curriculum from this program Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday.
And we are still keeping up with our extracurriculars
and our supplemental stuff that we do outside of the home.
So they are also doing a Spanish lesson,
an immersion program once a Week,
they are doing instrument music lessons.
They each have an extracurricular that they're into right now
that they love. My daughter's doing musical theater
and my son is doing LaCrosse.
So they're finding their.
They're finding their bliss and leaning into it,
which I love. And we still have that time to be together as a family
and travel and have adventures
and do unit studies at home
and other supplemental stuff that we wanna do.
So this is a big step.
I can't wait to take you guys along on this journey,
because co op life is very different than homeschooling at home.
And I kind of brought you guys along on what we were doing last year,
and this year's gonna look a little bit different.
So stay tuned, and if you have any questions,
you can leave them in the comments.
I'm not gonna answer anything specific about,
like, my kids specific program or location for safety reasons.
But if you have any questions about co ops,
about curriculum, about homeschooling,
about the different ways to homeschool,
please leave them them in the comments,
and I'll answer them as best I can. Or,
you know,
collaboratively answer them if you have the answers in the comments
as well.